[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
35 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
Very excited about our
interview with Sharat Shroff
and Morgan McLean.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I think it's going
to be a really nice continuation
of the conversation we
had about Stackdriver with Aja.
I think it's going to be
a nice extension to that,
and people are going
to learn a lot.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Previous episode,
basically we covered,
how do you know if
something's wrong.
Today we're going to
be talking about how
do you know what is wrong.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, how do you
go about fixing it, and working
out what's going on there.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and at the end,
we're going to be
talking about environment
variables and Twelve-Factor
applications--
Twelve-Factor authentication,
that'd be pretty awesome.
That's really scary.
Twelve-Factor
applications and how
do you do those on
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
But before that, we
have not one cool
thing of the week,
but two cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: You insisted on
putting that second one in.
You were very
insistent about it.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yes, because I think
it's actually pretty cool.
It is a very short thing,
but actually, let's leave
that for the second one.
So yeah, let's create some--
MARK MANDEL: Mystery.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Mystery, yes.
So the first one comes from
our colleague, Paul Newson.
He's in a rotation.
So he's normally a
developer advocate.
But he's doing a
rotation as an SRE.
MARK MANDEL: A Site
Reliability Engineer.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
And it is a pretty
amazing thing to do.
He's learning a lot.
And the best part is
that he wrote about it.
He wrote a blog post.
It's called "Adventures
in SRE-land:
Welcome to Google
Mission Control,"
which sounds pretty epic.
And it is indeed pretty epic.
He describes a
little bit what he's
been doing for the
last couple months,
and basically why it is so cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's really
cool, because he's
going to do a series of blog
posts outlining and documenting
his experiences being
a reliability engineer.
And I think also,
we might have him
on the podcast at
some point soon.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: I think he
might have agreed to do that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, there may
have been chasing involved.
We may have had
to lock him down.
But we got him.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, apparently he's
busy doing something,
like maintaining
the stability of the cloud.
No, no, no.
MARK MANDEL: So not important.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, not as important
as a podcast, obviously.
Anyway, so we're looking forward
to have Paul in the podcast.
Very excited about that.
And the second cool
thing of the week.
It is-- pretty sure video
is around five minutes,
and our dear friend, Miles Ward,
Head of Solutions for Google
Cloud Platform, describes
what Google Cloud Platform is,
and how is it part of Google,
and why Google has a cloud.
And it is a very short video.
It's only five minutes.
But if you're
curious about it, I
think it's a very
interesting one.
It covers many things
like machine learning
and things like that.
So just have a look.
The link is in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Wonderful.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Great.
So I guess it's time to go talk
with our friends, Sharat Shroff
and Morgan McLean.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds like fun.
So we are joined today
by two product managers
who work on Google Cloud,
Sharat Shroff and Morgan McLean.
How you both doing today?
SHARAT SHROFF:
Doing good, thanks.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
Doing great, yeah.
MARK MANDEL:
Wonderful, wonderful.
So the standard question we
ask everyone when they come
on the podcast is, who are you?
What's your history?
What do you get up
to here at Google?
Sharat, why don't
we start with you?
SHARAT SHROFF: Sure.
I'm Sharat Shroff.
I am a product manager working
on developer infrastructure
on Google Cloud.
What that really
means is that I'm
extremely interested
in developer workflows.
How developers write
code, how they ship code,
how they diagnose their
application, how they debug it,
and so on.
I'm right now focused a lot on
application-level diagnostics
and monitoring.
MARK MANDEL: Cool,
and yourself, Morgan?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yes.
I'm Morgan McLean.
I'm also a product manager.
I'm on Stackdriver Trace.
And like Sharat, I
have a big interest
in software diagnostics.
I previously worked in cloud
services at other companies.
And Trace really excites me
because it both gives you
a view of how your
application is running,
and what services are talking
to which other services.
And you can also see
really interesting details
about latency, or
other unique insights
into how your web
application works.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So recently, we had an episode.
We talked with our
colleague Aja Hammerly.
And we discussed Stackdriver
as a monitoring tool.
But now when you
introduce yourselves,
you use this other
word, diagnosis.
Could you tell us a little
bit about what is diagnosis,
and how is it different
to monitoring?
SHARAT SHROFF: Got it.
So when Aja spoke
about Stackdriver,
she covered a lot of the system
and infrastructure monitoring
pieces.
And this is basically
telling the users-- typically
in that case, Ops, or DevOps,
or our developers-- how
their infrastructure is
behaving at any given time,
at one specific time.
What Morgan and I are focused
on is basically around
when the user knows
that they have
a problem in their
application, how
do they go about finding the
root cause of the problem.
So all the various
tools that you
need to discover exactly
where the problem is occurring
and why the problem
is occurring,
that's where we are
really focused on today.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah,
I think it would
be fair to say that one
is more Ops focused.
That would be like Stackdriver
monitoring and alerting.
It tells you when
something's wrong
and it tells you from a very
high level perspective what
is wrong and what's failing.
And the diagnostic tools,
like Trace and Error
Reporting and Debug
can be used to actually
find out in your code or in
your architecture, the root
cause of the problem
so you can fix it.
SHARAT SHROFF: And the
other way to think of it
is these are effectively two
sides of the same puzzle.
So when you have a problem
with your software,
you look at it in
two different places.
Is there a problem
in my system, or is
the problem in my application?
And based on that, you
need different tools.
You need different tools
to find out why and where
the problem is occurring.
And so much of what
we're talking about
is at the application
level, which
tends to be-- which
is basically around,
how do you connect the
code to what is actually
happening in production?
MARK MANDEL: All right, cool.
So I guess at a high level,
what tools are available?
Like say something goes wrong.
I'm getting errors in my code.
Where does that lead me
to within Stackdriver?
SHARAT SHROFF: So
today, we've got
a few tools that are out there
that users can actually use.
Logging of codes--
what I consider
logging is-- logging
is the one place,
is the one tool that every
application developer can use.
If they don't have any
other tools available,
you can always go to logging,
because you can always go back
to your code, instrument
your code to output something
to logs, then go back
and look at logs.
You can probably build some
kind of an automation to scrape
through logs, and
so on and so forth.
Or even better, the
one really cool feature
that exists today in
Stackdriver is to take the logs,
export it to BigQuery.
And you then have the
full power of BigQuery
to analyze your logs.
So that is always there.
In addition to logs,
we have some tools
like Trace-- and Morgan can
tell you a lot about Trace.
We have Error Reporting,
which basically,
if you think of Trace as
the view of the application
from a latency point of view,
Error Reporting is really
looking at your
application errors
no matter where
they're occurring,
and be able to analyze your
application almost instantly.
And then the fourth tool
that you have available
is the debugger,
Stackdriver Debugger,
which effectively takes a
snapshot of your application
at runtime.
It doesn't pause the
application or anything.
It almost at runtime takes a
snapshot of your application
and allows you to inspect
the state of the application
as the application is
serving out requests.
So those are the tools
that you have today.
There is more coming
online, but this is the four
I can talk about right now.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, cool.
So let's take a
couple of scenarios
and talk through them, and
see what tools we end up.
So, OK.
The classic example, I
guess, is I'm getting
an error in my application.
Where does that go?
Does it go to logging?
Does it automatically get
caught by Error Reporting?
I've written some
code in my app,
but I don't know-- where
does that information go to,
and how can I find it?
How can I know something
bad has happened?
SHARAT SHROFF:
Yeah, so errors can
manifest in a couple of
different ways, right?
The one sure place where it
will manifest is in logs.
But error reporting is
always scraping through logs.
So the moment you
have an application,
an App Engine--
there is no setup
needed at all, by the way,
for any of these tools.
There is no additional step of
integrating agents or anything
like that.
If you have an App
Engine application, boom.
Error Reporting
will work for you.
And the moment you
have your application
and it starts throwing
out some kind of errors,
Stackdriver Error Reporting
will be able to immediately,
one, identify that it's
a new type of error,
and alert you that an
error has occurred,
and three, give
you more statistics
about that error itself.
How often that
error is occurring.
It can give you a
distribution of that error.
Is it happening 10 times a
second, or 10 times a week,
or whatever it is.
You have all the
statistics available just
by going to one URL.
So you would get notified.
So in this scenario
that you described,
you would see a
notification that
tells you that, hey, there's
a new error that has occurred.
And then you would basically
go in and click on that link,
and you would then get all
the details about that error,
including capturing
the call stack.
So you will basically--
associated with that error,
we capture the
entire call stack.
Not only do we capture
the call stack,
we actually pause through
that call stack and identify
the areas which are
most likely of interest.
Because we look at
the call stack--
whenever I look at a call
stack, my eyes kind of
glaze over because it's huge.
It's insane, right?
So what Error Reporting
does really well
is it basically says, OK, great.
We have sifted through
the call stack.
Here are these five lines that
you need to really look at.
And you have everything
else available.
If you want to, but it basically
hints to the user, saying,
thse are the five lines
that you've got to look at.
MORGAN MCLEAN: And
what I've found--
part of the beauty
of Stackdriver
and the Stackdriver
suite of tools
is in situations like
this, where maybe there's
an error occurring
in your application,
so you find it in
Error Reporting.
Or you've been notified that
there's very high latency
in your application.
You can actually jump
between the tools, right?
So in the experience
for Error Reporting,
I believe you can
launch into Debug.
In Trace, for example, if you
find a very high latency trace,
you can launch into the
logs for those traces.
And so it's not so much
a collection of products
that you're using, or
a collection of four
different features that
Stackdriver offers to you,
it's really a suite
for diagnostics.
Right?
So even once you
isolate the problem
with one of the
lenses in that suite,
whether that be logging
or error reporting,
you can then follow up
and get more analysis
from some of the other
functionality that we offer.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, I
think Morgan brings up
a really interesting point,
here, and a really valuable
point.
If we were going
about building tools,
we would just keep
churning out tools.
But the real thing is
we're really focused
on developer, DevOps workflows.
It's really understanding,
OK, something bad
is happening with
your application,
and you have been notified.
Or should we eventually
notify you, and where
you're being notified.
We aspire to hold your
hand right from the point
where you first get
that notification
and take you all the way to
where the problem is occurring,
while, at the same time,
corralling information
from the application, from
the user themselves as they're
navigating through the journey,
and from the system when
we have it, which is why
we're all under Stackdriver.
And where possible,
the application's
customers, the
application's users.
So in App Engine, for
example, Error Reporting
can tell you how many
customers have been impacted
by this specific error.
So we try to combine all
this information in order
to help you do two things.
Find you, bring you to the root
cause, and help you prioritize.
Do I need to drop everything and
immediately jump in right now,
or is it something that I
can wait and address later?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah,
and some cases,
there are even suggestions
on how to fix it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool,
so that means I
guess I could get an error
notification through Error
Notifications that could then
make me go look at some logs.
Maybe from there as
well, I could jump
into either Trace or Debug.
I can jump around
as necessary to see
where that thing's happening.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yep.
And there's further integration
coming in as we keep building.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
There's a step that I'm
missing out, though, which is,
so you say that you can
jump directly from the Error
Reporting to the code.
How is the code linked
to your project?
Could you talk a
little bit about that?
How do I do that?
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, so the
place, the linkage point
occurs typically at the call
stack level, where we basically
show you a line number, a
filename or the line number.
And if the user, or
if the project has
the source code
linked to the app--
then we can actually do this.
And there are three
different sources right now,
three different repos
that we support.
Of course, there's the
Google Cloud repository.
So if your code is hosted
in Google's Cloud repo,
then we are able to,
from the call stack,
infer the correct version
of the application code,
and basically allow you to
navigate directly from the call
stack to the application
code, and, with one click,
allow you to take a snapshot.
And I'll describe a little
bit later about what
the snapshot really does.
But in addition to
that, if your code
resides in GitHub or
Bitbucket, then you can link.
It's a very straightforward way
to link your code that resides
in GitHub repo or Bitbucket.
But the moment you do that,
then Stackdriver Debugger
will very easily be able
to navigate to the source.
That's one of the--
the magic sauce
that exists in all of this.
MARK MANDEL: So that's that
sounds really interesting.
Are there any limitations that
people should be aware of,
maybe by either language or it
only works in certain products?
SHARAT SHROFF: Right
now, much of what
we're talking about works
very well for almost all
the major languages
in App Engine.
We are very rapidly
building out the same kind
of support for Compute
and Container Engine.
And in Compute
Engine, you will see
the matrix, the
language support matrix,
is not necessarily consistent
between Trace and Debugger
and Error Reporting, but we
are, in a matter of, let's say,
months, I think--
MORGAN MCLEAN: In Trace, weeks.
SHARAT SHROFF: We will
have more and more support.
MARK MANDEL: We won't lock
you down to timelines.
I wouldn't want
to do that to you.
I understand.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
Yeah, but certainly,
in the upcoming quarter
and the quarter following,
at least for Trace-- I can
speak specifically for Trace,
but I believe it's
true for the others,
that support for GCE and
GKE is our top priority,
because the experience
on App Engine
is excellent for Stackdriver.
And we want to make sure
that the experience is
excellent on those
other Compute platforms.
MARK MANDEL: And just
so we're clear, too.
Is that both App Engine
standard and flexible?
MORGAN MCLEAN: I think that's--
SHARAT SHROFF: It's App
Engine standard right now.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
All right, so I'll
ask the question,
I guess, from a
different perspective.
Say I'm a developer.
I'm working on Google
Cloud Platform.
Is there anything that I can do
to put in place these practices
as I'm building my application?
Are there tools or
agents or anything
that I should be
doing from the outset?
Maybe for some of those things,
more like GCE or other stuff.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah,
so I know this touches
on a previous point.
If you're using App
Engine, of course,
you're getting all
this functionality
for free, basically, right?
The beauty of it is that you
don't have to think ahead.
You don't have to start
linking libraries,
or go to a third party
solution or anything like that.
If you're a developer,
however, on GCE or GKE,
then you should look for some
of the libraries that we offer.
For example, if you just
go and spin up a VM on GCE
and don't do any
additional work,
Trace won't receive any
data from your application,
and you'll go to the Trace
panel on Cloud Console
and you won't see any traces
because we didn't capture any.
But if you look at the
Trace documentation
on the Google Cloud
Platform website,
we have links there
to our Java library,
and an OJS library for Trace,
and links for Python and Go
should be arriving shortly.
And those are libraries that you
can integrate with your code.
And depending on the
library and depending
on when you're
listening to this,
we'll have different
levels of support.
But already today, if
you're using an OJS library,
for example, you
link the library.
You get it through NPM
in your application,
and suddenly, you're
collecting traces.
Some of the other ones like
Java, the initial release,
you'll have to sprinkle
it throughout your code.
And so it's not just linking it.
There's a little
more work than that.
And so that is something
you should think about
while you're developing.
We hope to move beyond
that in the future,
but that's where we are today.
So yeah, if you're on
GCE, GKE, and you're
using Java or a
language other than Node
and you want to use
Trace and, I think,
some of the other features, you
should be thinking about this.
And you should be thinking about
the telemetry that you want
to collect, the instrumentation
that you want to send us
and that we can provide
to you, and focus
on what's the most useful.
If Trace is very
useful to you, then you
should go use one of those
libraries and sprinkle it in.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, I think
much of what Morgan said
applies to Debugger
and Error Reporting,
except the languages that are
fleshed out are different.
MORGAN MCLEAN: That's
a good point, yeah.
SHARAT SHROFF: Debugger has
only got a few languages,
supports a few languages in GCE.
They're all going at
their own different paces,
but in a matter of months,
we'll be at a point
where we will have covered
all the major languages.
But the other facet of the
question that you just asked
is, are there APIs-- and
correct me if I'm wrong.
So are there APIs that
developers can use to leverage
the functionality that
comes with, say, Trace,
or Debugger, or
Error Reporting so
that they can incorporate it
in their existing workflows
or dashboard?
And that is already there.
So almost all
the-- so everything
from Logging, Trace, Debugger,
Error reporting, all of these
have APIs that's all available
through the one platform API.
So if you want to be able
to extract traces or write
traces-- we'll talk
about write as well.
But if you want to
extract any of this data
so that you can host it in your
own dashboard, you can do that.
And so that's something
to think about as well.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Or if you want to
submit data to those services.
But perhaps we haven't
provided a library yet.
You're certainly welcome to
do so through those APIs.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, I mean,
if you think of the example
where-- not everything is
traditional request responses,
right?
So you could have a scenario
where a developer is trying
to diagnose latency of
one specific function
that he or she has written down.
So you have the ability to
say, here is a custom span that
and I would like to capture.
And you insert a start
time and an end time.
That is not something
that is automatically
instrumented for you, but
a developer can do it.
So she or he can
basically say, here
is a custom start
and a custom stop,
and have this whole
thing span represented
in the context of my entire
request so that they can say,
this function adds
x milliseconds
to my overall request.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah,
and that would be useful
even if you're on App Engine.
If you're calling an
external service or something
and you're
instrumented otherwise,
you can still submit that
data through the API.
SHARAT SHROFF:
And you can do all
of that using that API
that we were talking about.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So what
you were talking about now
made me think about a
best use case, which
is I have one new
version of my code.
And I want to make sure
if it's faster or slower.
How could I go to do that?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah, so
I think you'd probably
want to start in Trace
because this is primarily
a latency analysis.
And Trace actually has
some pretty unique features
that allow you to do this.
So in the past, or if you're
using other tools, what
you might do is take
a collection of traces
before and after the
different versions
and do a manual
comparison, and probably
eyeball it and see if
the latency has changed.
But Trace has a feature
called analysis reports that
will do this for you
both automatically,
or you can create custom ones.
So every day, you're
submitting data for Trace,
whether that's because you
have an App Engine application
or you're submitting it
through one of our libraries
or through the trace
API-- every day,
we go and do comparisons
day by day and version
by version of the latency
of your application.
So let's say you rolled
out a new version
and you didn't do or take
any additional actions.
Next time you go to
the Cloud Console,
you'll see that there's
actually a comparison
in that section of
the Trace UI that
did a comparison day by day.
And if the latency
has significantly
changed either for
better or for worse-- but
if the profile of
latency has changed,
we will both alert
you and give you
sample traces that let you do
that comparison for yourself.
Secondly, if you want to
do a manual report, which
you can do immediately--
so you don't
have to wait for the next
automated one to come through.
You can trigger a manual
report to do either a version
by version comparison,
or a time comparison.
Let's say you could
compare yesterday's traces
to all of the traces collected
over the last month on average.
And it will run that same
analysis report for you
and tell you if there's
been a significant change
in the profile of latency
for your application,
or for a particular component
of your application.
Or you can do it per
endpoint or something
like that, if you have
microservices architecture.
And it'll also, once again,
give you those sample traces
so you can actually
get examples, and maybe
click through on a
few and go, oh, maybe
the database or something
slowed down after we
rolled the version forward.
Or calls to this
service slowed down.
And so you can actually very
rapidly isolate what changed.
And then you can use that
to jump into other tools
like Debug to find out
specifically why it changed.
SHARAT SHROFF: And
Error Reporting as well
is version-aware.
So the moment you push out
a new version and a new kind
of error, or a new
error starts occurring,
it's automatically captured.
And you always have the ability
right there on the top--
MORGAN MCLEAN: You can filter.
SHARAT SHROFF: You can
filter down by version.
So you can say, here is
the version A, version B.
But it's good to also
highlight at this point
the underlying
emphasis on trying
to remove some of the
operational friction
where we would
prefer, we would like
to remove some of this what
I would call grunt work so
that developers can focus
all their effort on creating
while Google's got their back.
Right?
Basically, when a new
version rolls out,
we'll be aware of it.
And not only will
we be aware of it,
we'll always compare it
with what's happening,
with your previous version.
And if we see significant
amount of divergence
in any of these,
whether it's latency,
or availability,
or errors, we'll
immediately service that app.
We'll always be able
to link those errors
to the right
version of your code
so that we can allow you to
very quickly navigate through
to the problem.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, we're running out
of time, but what could
you recommend for our listeners
if they have never tried any
of the Stackdriver features?
What is the first
thing they should do?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Well, if
you're on App Engine,
you should just go use it.
We have pretty good
adoption on App Engine,
but there's no reason to not
use Stackdriver on App Engine,
because you get all
these tools for free.
We're already collecting
instrumentation data.
If you have a large,
important set of applications
on App Engine, you should go
try out the Stackdriver suite
immediately.
And I think you'll find
that it's really useful.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Great.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, the
other thing I would emphasize
is, it's as simple as clicking
through to a tab on the Cloud
Console, and you'll
be able to see.
It's all under the
Operations tab group.
And you'll just be
able to click on it,
and everything
should be working.
And once you do
that, everything else
is just turned on automatically
for App Engine standard.
And we will continue to have
that same level of focus
towards minimal amount of setup
needed so that users can use
that when we have the same
offerings available in Compute
and Containers, and [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: So yes,
we are running out
of time just a little bit.
But is there anything
else you'd like
to add that we haven't
either covered, or maybe
haven't mentioned,
or something you'd
like to plug about Stackdriver
or Stackdriver diagnostics
stuff.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, so the one
thing that I want to emphasize
is, all the features
that you hear
about in diagnostics,
whether it's logging,
or Trace, Debug,
Error Reporting.
All of these features
that we enable completely,
automatically out
of the box, we are
obsessive about performance of
the overall application itself.
What I mean by that is the
footprint that we use in order
to do this-- the
amount of overhead that
is added to these applications
in order to capture all
these diagnostics is in
the order of microseconds,
or single-digit millisecond
is the way to think of it.
So we want to make
sure that we are not
adding an additional burden
to the application itself.
The second thing is, basically
every one of these things
that we capture.
Every one of these pieces of
information that we capture
is basically
curated, is basically
analyzed by some of
our [INAUDIBLE] here.
One example to think
of is Trace insights.
We have about a billion traces,
more than a billion traces,
easily more than a
billion traces coming
into our system every day.
Each one of these
traces is analyzed
to identify points
of suboptimality
within that, so
that we can actually
say, hey, I'm making too many
datastore [INAUDIBLE] calls
MORGAN MCLEAN: Or your
memcache calls are very slow.
SHARAT SHROFF: Or memcache
calls, or something like that.
So we identify
every single trace
so that we can then provide,
service all of that information
to the developer.
The third thing to call out
is, if you want to basically go
from identifying a
problem, or identifying
the location of a problem,
to the root cause,
there isn't a better
tool than Debugger.
The way to think of the
debugger is it basically--
I think one of the engineers
who wrote this tool describes it
really well.
It's like taking an
x-ray of a person who
is running without
stopping the person, right?
You can see the internals
of the entire system.
I've got some of the best
stories around very interesting
bugs that Debugger has
uncovered just by the ability
to have a very detailed
view into the working
of the application without
ever pausing this application.
MORGAN MCLEAN: It's
like a snapshot.
SHARAT SHROFF: It's a snapshot.
And to reproduce a
similar functionality,
it often takes developers days.
One way to think of it is
very often, if you're in Debug
and try to find the
root cause of a problem,
you would go instrument
some lines of code.
You would again go through
the validation and deploy.
Again, go back and
analyze the code.
Again, do this
thing multiple times
until you've probably
found the right thing.
With Debugger, [INAUDIBLE]
while the problem is occurring.
Even if it's happening in
production, no problem.
Just click, take a snapshot.
Boom.
You'll very quickly
be able to say, ah,
there is a risk condition
that I didn't see.
You don't have to reproduce that
anywhere in a test environment.
MORGAN MCLEAN: You
don't have to redeploy.
SHARAT SHROFF: You just
debug in production, right?
And that just is spectacular.
When customers use it
and I hear the wow,
it's very exciting for
us building these tools.
MORGAN MCLEAN: And
correct me if I'm wrong.
I think that actually works
across App Engine and GCE
and GKE, right?
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah, many
GCE languages are already
supported, so many of this
is available in GCE and GKE
as well.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well yeah, like I said, I think
we are running out of time.
So I think we're going
to have to cut it there.
But thank you very much to
both of you for joining us.
We really appreciate it.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
You're very welcome.
Thank you for having us.
SHARAT SHROFF: Thank you, folks.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Thanks
again to Sharat Shroff
and Morgan McLean for sharing
their very deep knowledge
on Stackdriver, especially on
the diagnostics parts of it.
I discovered many
different tools
that I'm going to be using
next time I have an issue.
I'm not looking forward
to having any issues,
but for next time,
I know what to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no
I actually kind of want
to sit down with Debugger
now and just poke at my app
and just see what it's doing,
just at a given point in time.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: I had
some fun with the debugger.
And I got to say, it's
pretty impressive.
Basically, instead of just
adding more and more logs,
which is normally what I
do-- that's how I do it.
Rather than just logging every
single value in your function,
you just put a
little breakpoint.
And you don't actually
stop it, so it is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Perfect.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So let's go
with the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you
posed a really interesting
on when we were
sitting here earlier.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
the question of the week
is, OK, so I've been reading
about Twelve-Factor-- not
authentication again.
Twelve-Factor applications.
And by the way, if you
don't know what they are,
you should just
search that on Google
and read a little bit about it.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put
it in the show notes.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
one of the things
that the Twelve-Factor
application manifesto says
is that you should always deploy
basically the same artifact
everywhere.
So the same compiled binary,
or the same docker image,
or whatever you're doing.
And the differences between
QA and test and production
should be done with
environment variables.
So the question is,
how do you do that?
How do you do
environment variables
on Google Cloud Platform?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
there's a few different ways
you can do it depending on
which product you're on.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically.
So depending, if you have GCE,
GAE, and GKE-- so if you have--
MARK MANDEL: Say that
three times quickly.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: No,
I cannot do that.
I'm pretty surprised
I did it once.
So on App Engine,
there's actually a thing
called environment variables.
So you can set them
very easily inside
of the app.yaml or
app.xml, depending
on the language you're using.
And basically, it
allows you to say, hey,
you know the variable
name-- I don't know.
Not host.
That's a bad idea.
But let's go with something like
database URL equals something.
And then when you access it
from your App Engine code,
it actually looks like it's
an environment variable.
So every language has different
ways of accessing those.
But basically, it will behave
like any other environment
variable.
So what about on GKE,
on Container Engine?
MARK MANDEL: So GKE,
you have a few options.
Quite similarly to App
Engine, when you're
sending your YAML files
or your configuration
up to your Docker containers,
or GKE itself up to Kubernetes,
you can explicitly set
environment variables
in that YAML file.
But if you want something
that's maybe a little bit less
coupled, a little
bit more flexible,
you can do things like
config maps or secrets.
Those are ways to send up
information up to Kubernetes
with a given name that can
then be looked up later.
Those can be exposed
in a variety of ways,
from volumes and a
variety of other things.
But one of the ways
you can do that
is sending up data as
environment variables.
Secrets tend to be used when
you've got private information,
like usernames and passwords.
Config maps are used
when you have tech stuff,
like maybe, where is
my database pointed at?
Or maybe, where is the
URL for my mailing list?
Or maybe it's just like, hey,
this is the version of this app
that I want to display.
It's got a blue button
rather than a red one.
Less sensitive stuff.
So you have a variety
of options there.
Now on Compute Engine, so if I'm
running just a straight-up VM,
is there an option
that I can use there?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So one of the
things that you can imagine
is you log into your
instance and you just
set the environment
variable there.
Whatever OS you're running-- so
let's say you're using Linux.
You go export, whatever,
equals whatever.
And that will work.
But next time you
start a new instance,
it will not have those values.
So how do you do it if you
want to set those environment
variables across
all your instances?
Well, the best way is actually
using the metadata server,
metadata server API.
And is just a key value store.
So it is very simple.
And whenever you are
going to set a new one,
all of the instances
that are already running
will have access
automatically to that value.
So it can be very
useful for if you're
doing something
like the database,
like a link to the database.
And if at any point you
need to change that,
you just change it.
And if your code is regularly
checking that variable out,
everything will just work.
It is also completely safe,
so you can store secrets
if you want to.
It is encrypted, so there's
no problem with that.
And finally, the cool thing
is that this will actually
work anywhere.
So you can access
those variables
from Compute Engine,
obviously, but also
from App Engine and
Container Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Now do I need
to call an API to do that,
or is that just
inherently available?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So if
you're in App Engine,
you need to use an API.
It is very simple.
It's an [INAUDIBLE] API.
And I'm almost sure
there's a library for that.
But even if there was
not, it's just basically a
get request onto
a URL that is only
accessible from inside
Google Cloud Platform.
So basically, only
you have access.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I can do exactly
the same thing from a Docker
container inside GKE as well.
Perfect.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is very simple,
but it is incredibly powerful.
And you can use it from
anywhere in your projects.
So it makes a very easy way
to integrate different pieces
of your architecture.
MARK MANDEL: Now that's cool.
So if I ever wanted
to share, say,
some information
across an App Engine,
and GKE, and maybe
a GCE project that I
wanted to stay the same
across all of them,
that could be my
central location for
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
[INAUDIBLE] server API,
it's going to be
the best place, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Excellent.
OK, well Francesc,
are you going to be
anywhere fun and interesting
in the next coming weeks?
I know you're relaxing now
that GopherCon is over?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yes,
GopherCon is over.
The videos will be
up sometime soon.
And in the meanwhile, I'm going
to be chilling on the beach
soon.
But don't worry.
We're going to be
having episodes nonstop.
MARK MANDEL: There's no break.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
There's no break.
I'll be just somewhere
enjoying the beach.
But in the meanwhile, I don't
have any interesting plans
to share, which is awesome.
I think that your case is
a little bit different.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so I had some things
cooking in the fire for a while,
and they've come to fruition.
So when this comes out,
the week after that,
I will be in Israel doing
multiple events in Israel.
So I am going to the GDG
Cloud Tel Aviv meet-up.
I'll be there on the 25th.
The day after that, I will
be at JavaScript Israel
on the 26th, that evening.
And the main event I'm
coming up for is GameIS.
They have a development day
talking about game development.
I'm going to be showing some
Firebase content off there.
So I'm going to be running
all over the place in Israel.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
After that, I'm taking
a bit of a vacation.
Like I said, we've
got podcast episodes.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Very
well-deserved vacations.
Great, well thank you so much.
Have a good trip.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And
see you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]